a North Carolina man charged with
killing his wife after he says he took
too much Kaufman Essen remains in jail
Matthew Phelps appeared before a judge
for the first time yesterday he is
charged with first degree murder in the
death of his wife Lauren Phelps Jericka
Duncan shows us what happened when he
called first responders tarika good
morning good morning it was less than a
year ago that Matthew Phelps exchanged
vows with his wife Lauren well now he
could face the death penalty if
convicted of her murder and Phelps
appears to have confessed to the crime
during a 911 Matthew Phelps kept his
head down as he entered a rally
courtroom Tuesday charged with stabbing
his wife Lauren to death do you think
he's gone beyond any Hill the 28 year
old called 911 in the middle of the
night police released the call but
altered the voice as required by state
law Phelps says he took too much cough
medicine to course even the coldest cuz
I know what to make you children a lot
of times I can't sleep at night CBS News
medical contributor dr. David agus is
skeptical we've been using this coffin
cold medicine for literally 50 plus
years this is not a reaction that I've
ever heard of to a medicine like this in
a statement Bayer one of the makers of
course Eden said patient safety is our
top priority there is no evidence to
suggest that coricidin is associated
with violent behavior hi everybody it's
Lauren Lauren Phelps worked with the
youth at her church in May she
celebrated the couple's six-month
wedding anniversary
writing on Instagram I love our days
spent together and wouldn't take it back
for anything
[Music]
it's a very tragic situation and at the
same time we have to ask everybody to
withhold judgment there's a lot to this
story
in the future Matthew Phelps is being
held without bond and is due back in
court later this month the memorial
service for Lauren Phelps was held
earlier this week at the same church
where she got married her obituary
identifies her by her maiden name and
makes no mention of her husband Norah
terrible story three kids right I love
that David agus made the point in all
the history of the cough syrup they have
never heard of that kind of reaction to
it absolutely more to that case agreed